Donald Trump appears to turn on his own
anti-abortion supporters in a truth
sensual post truth Central or truth
social or however you want to call it
essential yeah that thing the thing
that's failing uh where he is now
blaming Republicans for taking two
extreme uh position on the issue of
abortion now what's really really
interesting about this is that number
one it's enraging many Trump supporters
number two there's a kernel of truth to
it but number three it misses the really
big picture of why a lot of these
Republicans lost which is that they were
absolutely terrible terrible candidates
so let's talk about it Newsweek
reporting Donald Trump turns on his own
supporters over abortion Donald Trump
has blamed the Republican party's
disappointing midterm performances on
the abortion issue rather than the
failure of his endorsed candidates so
the truth Central post is as follows
quote vote this is a beautiful new
year's message from Trump quote it
wasn't my fault that the Republicans
didn't live up to expectations in the
midterms I was 233 and 20. that's his
endorsement record it was the abortion
issue poorly handled by many Republicans
especially those that firmly insisted on
no exceptions even in the case of
capital r rape capital I incest or
capital L life of the mother that lost
large numbers of capital V voters also
the people that pushed so hard hard for
decades against abortion got their wish
from the U.S Supreme Court and just
plain disappeared not to be seen again
plus Mitch stupid dollars I think that's
something about Mitch McConnell
um uh deploying money in what Trump
considers to be a stupid way so there's
a couple interesting things here first
of all I just want to remind you when
Trump touts that endorsement record of
233 and 20 remember many of us could
have that endorsement record and what I
mean by that is Trump mostly endorsed
incumbents including some who were
running essentially unopposed in heavy
red districts he endorsed the primary
winners in red districts it's not
difficult to rack up a lot of wins the
important thing is that the critical
races that would have made a difference
the contested races Mehmet Oz in
Pennsylvania and mastriano and Tudor
Dixon Trump failed on those and those
are actually the ones that really
mattered but more importantly Trump says
that the problem here was the abortion
issue so there's a couple things here
first of all is it true that running
against abortion with no exceptions is a
bad strategy for for Republicans yes
that is absolutely true there's limited
appeal because it's increasingly an
unpopular opinion more Americans than at
any point in the Roe v Wade era believe
that abortion should be usually legal in
most circumstances so taking a position
of no abortion no exceptions even in the
cases Trump mentions it is a bad idea
it's an inflexible position because you
can't end up compromising unless you
want to look like someone who's just
putting their finger to the wind when
you say just no abortion no exceptions
you're starting from a point of lack of
flexibility it doesn't match public
opinion sometimes focusing too much on a
single issue can hurt you because people
see you as oh that's the abortion guy or
gal you're not really going to deal with
this thing that's important to me or
that other issue or education or health
care or whatever the case may be so it
is accurate that a no exceptions
position on abortion is increasingly out
of step with public opinion and it
doesn't make sense but but but
this is also part of trump
never taking responsibility for anything
and being the victim it wasn't my fault
he starts his truth Central post by
saying they took these positions well
you endorsed them didn't you and the
reality is they picked terrible
candidates look at some of the people
they selected Kerry Lake a conspiracy
theorist who doesn't know anything about
anything and she almost won by the way
Blake Masters for Senate in Arizona
maybe one of the worst candidates in the
last 20 years Mehmet Oz a quack TV
Doctor Who it's not even clear really
lived in Pennsylvania to fight
um against John fetterman Doug mastriano
almost literally a January 6th rioter to
run against Josh Shapiro uncontroversial
good candidate
the right opinions on so many so many
issues Tudor Dixon Herschel Walker who
can barely even speak so was it the
abortion issue or was it really an issue
of poor candidates and I think we know
the truth
abortion is important
but the decision by the Supreme Court
was a little too early to affect the
2022 races as much as maybe some of us
on the left hoped and some of the
Republicans with that no exceptions view
on abortion did win
it was the terrible candidates that lost
now in terms of the impact uh on Trump's
supporters of trump saying this the
super pro-lifers are not happy and it's
sort of beyond the scope of this segment
to talk in more detail about that but
they there are some extreme the people
for whom abortion is the most important
issue and they hate it and want no
exceptions are very very unhappy with
what Donald Trump is saying we'll see if
it affects his 2024 candidacy which is
not exactly off to a brilliant start
let's now take a quick look at this
humiliating event that Donald Trump did
on New Year's Eve